[Music]
you can tell they really like it cuz
we're not talking we're here at rolling
Creamery and we're trying the rolled ice
cream taco you know I love ice cream I
post I have tram Victor's like every day
yeah if I'm gonna have a cheat meal it's
probably gonna be ice cream they make
ice cream on the pyre and plate yeah
they're like they rolled it it's so
interesting
yeah I wonder if it tastes any different
I'm guessing the texture a bit then
we'll see ah strawberry cheesecake it's
so pretty
you so cute I need an Instagram okay
I didn't think the texture would be any
different because of the rolling but
actually is a chewy that's real sweet
without so can you lick it like you try
looking
how'd that go nothing happens I like
that the more you need the more I've
given the show behind the one you know
when your normal eating ice cream you
have to like get a little while until
then you get to the comb and comb kind
of my favorite part this part you're
just like immediate cone and ice cream
combo Oreo powder on top I think it
might be Oreo crumbles maybe let's try
this let's roll hahaha looks like a
burrito I like eating that way so I can
kind of like lick it in my mouth instead
of chewing it right away it's chewy
again which is kind of nice it's a very
milky ice cream mmm not water now I like
the cheese extra for sure I feel like
I'm actually eating like a meal it's a
little bit closer to cookie dough yeah
cheering laughing eating like this is so
satisfying well then you have to buy
them again I can't
[Music]
this is what dreams are made of and then
here we go
the great thing about black sesame ice
cream is it's not as sweet it's a lot of
other it is so flavorful it's so
colorful
I think I have to have it in this I love
the taco code I like how I can eat it
all at once this is so like then they
rolled white so chewy because it's like
a layer or layer overruled
I'm weirdly converted to rolled ice
cream I didn't know that there would be
much of a difference but I really liked
this texture like everything to me
really it makes it just like more
favorite I think I really like that ice
cream is like evolving ice creams
getting fancier and fancier like what
can it do
[Music]